- What I'll do is name
a location in New York
and Tracy will tell us his
personal history behind it.
Here we go. Are you ready?
- Ready.
- Okay. The Bronx Zoo.
- I got lost in the Bronx Zoo
when I was about 11 years old.
(audience laughing)
I got lost.
I went with the camp, and my
guardian's name was Spencer,
and we got in the zoo,
and he told us not to feed
nothing, none of the animals.
What did little Tracy do?
I started throwing food at the chimpanzee.
He hit me with a switch on my
back and I ran and I was lost,
but then they found me about
two, three hours later.
- Okay, in your defense,
he hit you with a switch on your back.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I'd have left too.
Okay, wait. The old Yankee Stadium.
- I met my first wife
Sabina Morgan at gate four
because I worked at gate
four scalping tickets.
I scalped tickets and I sold
souvenirs and I sold pretzels.
I sold everything at gate four,
and also, that's where I
honed in on my sense of humor.
That's when I honed in on
my craft, selling souvenirs.
- [Kelly] That's awesome.
- I overcharged Lorne Michaels about $14.
(Kelly laughs)
Lorne, I owe you $14 for little bags.
- Little... Okay! (laughs)